you or someone you know may have been
diagnosed with head and neck cancer this
video will help you understand some of
the available treatment options
the most common type of head and neck
cancer called squamous cell carcinoma is
a disease where cancer cells form inside
the nose sinuses mouth throat voice box
or salivary glands your doctor will make
a treatment plan specifically for your
tumor it will be based on the location
of the tumor the stage of the disease
how far it has spread and your age and
general health
treatments may include one or more of
the following surgery radiation therapy
chemotherapy targeted therapy and
immunotherapy there are several types of
surgery depending on the size and
location of the tumor
surgery may be used to remove the cancer
or repair a function that was damaged by
the cancer
another treatment option is radiation
therapy it uses radiation to kill cancer
cells or stop them from growing external
radiation therapy uses a machine that
aims radiation at the cancer from
outside the body
internal radiation therapy uses a
radioactive source that gives off
radiation the radioactive source is put
inside the body into or near the cancer
chemotherapy fights cancer by using
drugs these drugs may act on the whole
body or they may act on one area
targeted therapy uses drugs that are
designed to target specific cancer cells
some of these drugs act by preventing
the cancer cells from growing and
dividing since these drugs mainly affect
the cancer cells
there's less damage to normal cells
immunotherapy helps your immune system
fight cancer cancer cells can sometimes
hide from the immune cells that attack
them
for example cancer and immune cells may
have proteins called checkpoint proteins
when they attach attack from immune
cells is stopped
some immunotherapy drugs for head and
neck cancer act by blocking the
checkpoint proteins from attaching to
each other as a result the immune cell
can attack and destroy the cancer cell
if you have questions about head and
neck cancer or any medications you have
been prescribed talk to your doctor it
is important to take your medications as
directed and report any side effects you
may have